MARK MIRCHANDANI:
On this episode,
we talked to doc.ai
about how they're
using Google Cloud for
their applications, chat
bots, and machine learning.
So can you tell me
a little bit more
about what you actually
use inside of Google Cloud,
for instance, the machine
learning and any other products
that you might use?
AKSHAY SHARMA: Definitely.
So a lot of what we
build on the cloud
is mostly on the Google Cloud.
So we use many different
services that Google offers.
We try to be as Cloud
Native as we can.
But there are some
important aspects
of Google Cloud that
makes our job easier
and gets to market sooner.
So largely, our ecosystem of
tools that we use on Google
Cloud-- so we use GKE,
the Kubernetes Engine.
It's a fantastic product
from Google, in my opinion.
We build a lot of microservices
that are based on Docker.
And then we are able
to rule that out
on GKE as multiple
nodes and pods.
And it brings in
autoscaling aspects
for us, which is fantastic.
So a lot of our data
collection microservices
are basically collecting
data across different apps
and users, but also
from our partners.
So one line of business
that doc.ai has is,
we have licensed these
technologies to our partners.
And they have millions
of users, from which we
are able to collect that
data that's coming in.
So all the data
that's collected by
these different microservices,
which has burstable capacity,
are actually stored on GCS,
the Google Cloud Storage.
So it's important
for us to understand
that Cloud Storage provides
the reliability that we need,
because then we can use
multiple clouds, if we need,
because it becomes a single
point of entry for us
to share data across
different clouds.
We also use many of the
databases that we have.
We use, obviously,
Cloud SQL proxy,
which makes the job of
being able to connect
to different services really
incredibly simple for us.
The other thing that we have
done well on Google Cloud
is be able to build
parallelization,
so that we can train many,
many jobs concurrently
or simultaneously,
so to speak, so we
can experiment with
different hyper-parameters.
We use BigQuery for a lot of
our data analytics downstream.
So based on how users are
collecting information,
especially around events
and other aspects,
we can throw it at
BigQuery and see
what are some interesting
correlations that we
can see there.
Most of our
machine-learning models
are built today
using TensorFlow.
We have found that to be
production-ready from get-go,
which is something we
are very happy about.
And I think it's also
easy to hire today,
relatively in the world
of AI and deep learning--
many of them are
actually being trained
on TensorFlow, which is a good
thing, with the help of what
Google is doing
across the ecosystem.
We also use some of the other
specific hyper-specialized AI
modules you have.
For example, Google
Vision API is
something we use for
extracting certain information
in the medical context,
specifically around pill
bottles and bounding boxes,
and things like that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So you also
mentioned NLP a little while
ago.
And then earlier, you
talked about the chat bots.
How are users using chat bots?
And what is doc.ai
doing with those?
AKSHAY SHARMA: It's
a great question.
So one thing I did not
mention is that doc.ai also
has several chat bots.
So we have a
direct-to-consumer chat bot,
which is for mental health.
So we have more than 600,000
users on the platform.
It's a chat bot that runs
off of Facebook Messenger.
What we have seen, the chat
bots is a very interesting
phenomena.
Because for certain
types of diseases,
patients prefer talking
to a bot, as opposed
to a medical
professional, because one,
medical professional
are not necessarily
available in that area,
where they have these issues.
And bots have no judgment.
So they are not being watched
or being judged by someone.
So we have mental
health chat bot.
But we also work with
a lot of our partners
to rule out very
vertical specific chat
bots, for example, for
insurance companies,
where we can do
member engagement.
We are also building chat bots
for a very specific disease
verticals in the future.
But what they do is
that they are somewhat
generalized enough, that now
we could take a model like that
and bring our own data and
throw our specific data
and train an improved
version of that,
that's somewhat focused in
the domain that we have.
Of course, we need a lot
of data for it to improve.
But then these models then
become really valuable,
where you could engage them,
for example, in chat bots, where
you could predict the next
set of sequence of things
that a user may ask.
So you can give them
better services right away.
Or there is enough
contextual memory
of the previous
conversation, so you know
how to engage the user further.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thanks
so much for coming in,
Akshay, and telling
us about how doc.ai
is working with the cloud.
AKSHAY SHARMA: Thank you, Mark.
This was really exciting.
I'm very happy to
be here and hoping
to see many more talks in
the world of health care.
That's important for
the general ecosystem,
that Google is doing
a great job in.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
Thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this
conversation with doc.ai,
check out the Stack Chat
playlist for more great videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]